the u.s department of education says
public school enrollment during the
pandemics dropped by more than one and a
half million some students have switched
to private schools some are doing
at-home learning and others have just
kind of vanished from the system cbs
news's carter evans explores america's
lost students from right here in las
vegas
at tate elementary in las vegas
counselors are working the phones we
were just concerned because they haven't
started the first day of school they're
looking for children still missing from
class weeks after the school year began
like seven-year-old george gomez so go
ahead and take a deep breath
the nervous second grader has not been
inside a classroom since kindergarten
after more than a year of remote
learning nice to meet you
his mom finally decided to enroll him
after a doctor convinced her what kept
you from putting the kids back it's kind
of like it was scary and concerned
because none of us had a cover shot at
all so we all got a shot do you feel
safer now yes sarah popek is the
school's principal we do have some
students who are not back because their
parents are concerned this zip code in
particular was hit very hard with covent
across town at orr middle school empty
desks are constant reminders of
classmates who vanished the campus
normally holds up to 1200 students this
year only 871 were expected and how many
showed up the first day of school we
basically 400 didn't show up 400 correct
that's a lot of students it is a lot of
students nationwide it's estimated up to
3 million children stopped attending
classes in person or online after
pandemic shutdowns last year your
funding is based on how many students
come to school if these students don't
show up it may cause a reduction in
staffing back at tate elementary george
is now catching up with his classmates
how does it feel to be back
administrators now plan to go door to
door to track down the remaining lost
kids carter evans cbs news las vegas